[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
very excited to have Jeff Barkov joining
us on the show hello hello thank you so
much for coming on thank you for
inviting me
very pumped for this for those who don't
know you have his background he's an 18
year old hacker who recently graduated
from Lowell High School in San Francisco
and committed to Rochester Institute of
Technology RIT for computer science in
2018 he organized San Francisco's first
high school hackathon and has since been
working at software startups in the bay
area including repli'd as well as launch
Darkly where he currently works so you
can find the links in the bio that's y
EV y eb dot bar as well as his Facebook
and LinkedIn profiles alright yeah but
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world I think things are
obviously there's a when it comes to
climate change who are maybe other
political circumstances there are
definitely things to be worried about
but at the same time there is a notable
amount of hope and optimism in a lot of
people that you can also feel assured
things will balance out in the end if
not turn out for the better I guess as
well I think like like a lot that's how
it goes at the larger scale for the
individual scale as well I think it's
really like whatever you want to see
there's very much possible for you to
make that happen for yourself and then
very I guess I'm very idealistic in that
sense but I think that's very much true
for everyone the global challenges we
have the gen Z and even the younger
generations going forth and wanting to
tackle those we have individual
capacities creative capacities that are
being unleashed at unprecedented rates
to do that which is very exciting that's
a good synthesis and then how about we
learn let's jump into more on the
journey side okay so you're born in
Moscow moved to s
when you're only three months old yes so
unfortunately I cannot run for president
but uh which who knows things may change
in the future who knows oh no I don't
know we'll see
cross your fingers who knows but this
part is crazy when did when did when she
born death so I was born completely deaf
and I was born in 2001 where at the same
time California did pass legislature so
that newborns would get with when
they're like two three days old they'd
get checked for a vision and hearing
however back in Russia they did not have
that and I never got that even when I
moved here so I was just like going
around not here and effectively for the
first two years of my life and it was
during this time that no matter where we
would live and I would always sleep
amazingly because I couldn't hear
anything I'm a parent to be confused but
and so it's like no matter what the hell
the neighbors were up to I just like
lying around and when I was about to
when I was about two years old it was
like he's not quite responding the way
we would expect a child a baby to be
responding and so I went to an
audiologist and they realized oh he has
profound hearing loss I am deaf in both
ears and so I got my first implant at my
right side when I was two and a half
years old and the second of my left was
five and so that's effectively like two
three years of not being able to learn
anything at all and so yes this is ten
years of speech therapy and I think it's
done be well whoa
and so then this is so what what is the
test that we currently use for awkward
checking on baby
Oh for checking on babies so like the
test whenever I go for an audiologist
appointment it's always the same and I
assume it's gonna be the same for
infantry what you do is you get you know
how Microsoft Word these other big
universities to have this big room with
either likes film spikes in the walls
supposed to capture all the sound they
have like they have a few of those and
at the hospital I've seen it's just like
my chambers yes like chambers like
really thick walls like the door looks
like something you see the bank just
like a thick door and so when you're
locked in it's very much silent they'll
have speakers in the corners of the room
or
and some other strategically placed
spots and we'll just play Bebe's oral or
they will have someone playing sounds so
for me the test that could be taken is
like they'll play a beep and they'll
play at a different pitches different
volumes and all either respond raising
my hand or maybe pushing a button in my
hand to say I've heard that sound or I
didn't hear that sound and the another
test that might be only for older people
might be like they'll play sentences
either plain audio or in some background
noise those have like a mound mall audio
and those say a sentence and so my job
is to respond or repeat the sentence so
for infants they might just the beeps
and if they see the baby going whoa
there's a there's a sound there they can
tell ok this infant has heard and
responded to the sound and so that's
probably the test that I receive when I
was younger and since I was not visibly
responding to any of the sounds being
displayed they derived I could not hear
and then what happened at two-and-a-half
on the right side so on so on both it
was the same thing in the same surgery
if you will on both sides where they
excuse the gory details they they they
sort of had cut open the skin and not
like all the way at the skull but like
Oh Mike's maybe halfway there if you
will they implant this device and I do
not know the technical specifics of it
of what they do it near the inner
cochlea or the inner ear but they are
supposed to hook some things up there as
well so that now the final product skins
closed up there is a device there and
after the surgery it was maybe a month
or maybe like a like a few weeks before
they can actually activate my implants
so I even after the surgery I couldn't
get it tested or anything so they turn
it on and the way this device works is I
think I showed you this earlier so this
outer device there's a I don't know
because there's this small flimsy
microphone at the end this picks up the
sounds through the air this little bulky
got the end is a battery so plug it in
the device turns on this part in the
middle at the brown part in the middle
that is a audio processor and so this
once it picks up the sound two converts
the sound into electric signals then
goes up to the head piece here and this
head piece sticks onto my head by a
magnet so that's how I've fallen off
getting lots of hair and you did get a
haircut so it doesn't just fall off too
easily and that's how it works I guess
and that's what I got in both sides and
it's like two three weeks before
activation in both sides remember
correctly and it was a four or five hour
surgery for one side which is pretty
remarkable because my youngest sibling
she's three and she's also deaf like me
and for her she got so you got both her
devices and in 3-4 hours like the same
tone take for me to get one and it's
activated one two weeks after which is
like half the time for me and so you can
see already there's a progression of
technology took 15 years but there was a
progression of Technology there and so
that step it's definitely showing how
how much earlier and earlier we can help
people that are either discern under
circumstances or whatever may be seen
and so with me I guess there might be a
different development developmental
story where for for my youngest sibling
uh she will probably be she didn't she
was unable to hear for like the first
five six months of her life before
getting her implants whereas I went
almost three years and so there might be
a different story of her being able to
almost live as a normal functioning
human whereas with me there was a there
was not lots of speech therapy there was
lots of extracurricular studying and
other activities for me to do and so
there's definitely that as well he's
doing an excellent job like you were
speaking extremely well today extremely
well and for someone to actually have
went through two years of time yeah -
without actually receiving input
auditory yeah and then to be able to
have science and technology do something
like that
yes to that receiver piece right by your
ear the audio processing and they're
being able to convert that into signal
into you to be s understand what's
happening I mean wow that's like
that we have that I mean it's also kind
of funny as well when especially here in
the valley oh I think some things for
grimas there we are so here in the
valley you might see a lot of people
there like other futures transhumanist
and they're all like starting to put
maybe small chips in the hands and I've
already I got a full auditory I got one
of my five quintessential senses been
replaced by technology so I feed them
all now and that is your cyborg yeah yes
what's the deal with your sister also
being uh it's definitely it's definitely
a genetic thing I'm neither a mom or dad
either neither my parents neither my
parents right above me genetically have
a hearing condition however I believe
there there was maybe grandparents or
great-grandparents who did have some
hearing impairment later in their life
so there is a it's probably a recessive
gene it makes most likely and so there's
me two siblings in the middle who or
both of which are their normal hearing
but they both wear glasses like me and
now the youngest one she's deaf like me
and she also wears glasses so she's like
this little mini-me yeah like dr. evil
with him anyway yeah yeah and then how
when you're growing up when did you
start programming so with me like
because I was deaf for two three years I
needed to catch up to my age group
somehow and the way that when just to
have my I would begin logic work books I
just like I'd go to school and then they
come home and it just continued study
and I'd began all this work books
working on these problems and whatever
else and lit that my parents found that
I had a bit of an aptitude for
mathematics and my dad who is an
engineer he's like okay this is before
like tech really took off a champ just
go there are some startups and there's
some bit of a community here we should
teach them computer science it will work
several years down the road when she's
looking for a job it's also very safe
career path as well and so I like I
started tinkering are taking her around
when I was maybe seven eight years old
nothing terribly substantial maybe what
you'd see in like a first intro to
programming course today in like a high
school course and like so scratch maybe
some click-and-drag blocks not
that will impress most people other than
myself if you know it's it like I'm okay
and but things became a bit more
proficient if you rode towards middle
school and high middle school when I was
taking some online courses for with C
Java some actual programming languages
something that could actually be applied
to an industry know that it was industry
ready at the time but something a bit
more irrelevant if you will tune modern
age and then in high school that's when
things really took off with going to
hackathons and other tech related events
and you started in high school going
into into hackathons yes it was my
freshman I know this is maybe on the
roster but I'll just go ahead now the my
first year of high school I went to my
very first hackathon it was hacking edu
you have these images to pull off as we
go yeah so this is a me just in the fall
when I was a sponsor at a hackathon
giving a talk but my freshman year of
high school
it was hacking into you that event was
1500 plus people or so and for me going
into that I the most I could say about
programming was like okay I have some
ideas of some concepts of recursion
functions and because I was like reading
the maybe a C textbook like that's as
much as it could see like okay I know
everything there's to know websites apps
those are just black magic and when I go
to the event the hackathon and the way
code a hackathons like an impromptu
science fair were for 24 36 hours you
make something and you present it to
judges and when I was there I said I was
there was pebble it's what it was
acquired by Fitbit so a company has died
just my first hackathon but before it
was acquired you could do you could make
Pebble watch apps and so I made this
little janky thing with like 90s colors
and retro themes and stuff and so now I
could see my probe my cooking skills on
technology other than a black box in the
computer on my wrist and it's got colors
now that just blew me away for one thing
and on top of that when I look around
the the whole event space and I see
people with websites and applications
and robots and all these things I then
saw wait these reasons it's like this
black magic is not a whole
beyond me it's something that even I can
pick up now and so since then I've just
been like going down Google rabbit holes
checking out stuff and medium
stackoverflow whatever else and just
really colliding all this information
and so that and I unfortunately ran them
through the same loop where every
hackathon I will pick up something new
I'll learn a lot and because there isn't
much the show just scrapped everything
so the event never happened effectively
but they did the thing I always do take
away from where the event is that I
learned a lot from it where I learned
something new I built I add on to my
giant hammer that is coding and so my
hammer gets bigger and bigger and now if
I wanted to sit down and make a website
I could swing that hammer I could make
it even want to make a mobile
application I could swing my hammer I
could make it it's about giving me this
capability that very much within
anyone's reach that I wanted to add to
my own personal though to my own toolset
and so that is something I've been
continuing the sense on this everlasting
loop but the thing that came as a result
of that is even as I took over as the
president of the coding Club of my high
school is that president of coding clubs
yes yeah yeah so that's how I learned
about my first hackathon there was a I
found the coding Club at my high school
and then once the leaders graduated I
took over I was the dictator effectively
and and with that I would always
continue going through this hack bunch
would be going to Bart Caltrain I've
even biked it's like at the start of the
SF Chronicle article where I biked
from SF to Palo Alto I stayed up
overnight on some red ball then I biked
from Palo Alto up to Fremont and they
stayed at that hacker that I won the
first hackathon my friends didn't come
to the second one so I was just hacking
and staying up on Red Bull though I did
win a video game tournament at the
second one so I want something at both
active bonds and so I biked through all
that at bikes I've done everything to go
around the Bay Area and but the thing is
every time I come back to my club for a
club meeting I tell them this fact that
was awesome hackathons are amazing I can
make thinks there's all these people
that are into coding and every time did
you feel like we can't throw out hours
to travel around the Bay Area
like we simply cannot do this so after
three years like this is like it's not
gonna happen in San Francisco if I keep
waiting for it to happen so I decided
[ __ ] it I'll make it happen
and so through many months of fun it was
my first time organizing a larger event
so as long it was a large learning
process along the way and so from that I
organized hacking the fog it was San
Francisco's first high school hackathon
and we had 75 100 people show up we had
quite a few sponsors from Facebook and
Google and it was these are huge
sponsors yes 75 people
yeah 75 100 I believe 500 and these are
the next images we have to are the
actual this was me at Los Altos hacks it
was God it was March this past year and
so I came as a mentor because I figured
I'd be much more mentoring yes much more
able to contribute to the atmosphere of
the event as someone helping out other
people be able to code and so that's why
it was a mentor here that is a she's
that's hugely you took leadership roles
he took mentorship roles when you were
young yes huge well I guess for like the
leadership and taken charge bit of it I
did martial arts for 10 years and I took
a few years back to it now my laws for
ten years - yes and so part of that part
of the one of the things I picked up
from that experience was sort of being
able to take on leadership in a group
and being able to help people lean
people and like teach people what I know
because obviously for every different
kind of person you'll have to share what
you know in different different forms
whether it's more verbally more visually
more maybe you want to include more
physical gestures when displaying
content or information yeah and so
realizing that there's everyone's always
in a learning mode everyone's always
learning something new and I have the
things that I know some things that
other people might not know I'm so
constantly being in this sharing and
teaching mode as well it definitely is
very viable a couple things oh sure um
one of the things that I want to mention
here is that you bring up this idea that
when you see a black box if you can take
incremental steps to learn how the black
box works you can all of a sudden start
seeing that you know how to make the
website you know how to make that so you
know how to build the robots you know
how to do the things that see or even
for us things like editing video you see
really beautiful video up and then
you're like how the hell they make it
well actually after like years of work
as well in the space like you can
actually start getting close to that
yeah so these are the very important
ideas though get kids tinkering building
making yeah young ages because then they
can see themselves in the space I'm very
impressed these are some of the photos
from the hack the fog the first high
school hackathon they organized in SF
that you know you guys play as well I am
slightly concerned about the Red Bull
thing well yeah definitely
I have racked up quite a caffeine
tolerance so that is minimal but like
comparing to either there comparing to
other engineers I know or other people I
know is like everyone's got varying
degrees of caffeine tolerance is like
okay right will be a static capacities
gonna change as you get older you're not
gonna be able to do things oh yes I am
yes definitely
with a lot of people I spend time with
there maybe five ten years older than me
and so it's very and so there's often a
lot of contrasting you were just oh yeah
you're pulling to all these all-nighters
28 year olds the last time we pulled an
all-nighter like that's what kind of the
responses I usually get and so there
comes in a powerful moment of wisdom as
well where it's like there are they're
just they're just like definitely these
things that I can take advantage and be
able to do now that won't be as possible
in the future that's so realizing these
things recognizing them and then being
able to enjoy them now yes and build yes
we build do all these crazy things slot
to these time before the before the
tools and capabilities that I would need
to physically do these things now are
gonna be gone I should do them now and
be able to enjoy them and even when I
can't do them in the future
I can still spend time like either with
the next young hacker future me whatever
that would look like then
be able to share my experiences my
little tips like no just separate your
redbull so you drink like a cannon out
every hour don't drink it all now
because you'll crash laters I don't know
these small tips and just I share that
because I have personal experiences and
empirical evidence I can say these
things are better or worse and so I can
still continue the flow of information
and continue sharing what I have even we
can't physically do those things is
there a way to be able to congregate you
know here you're at your hacks on your
75 to 100 people in a short bit of time
you're trying to you know that's why you
want the time together instead of
sleeping is to be able to hack these
things together and have something at
the end that you've built you know these
that's the funny thing is this is
definitely probably an age thing but
when you're like high school age you
can't go for a long time just off of
natural energy like I was drink more
caffeine than I should in my day but
you're like even with or without
caffeine I could probably go for 24
hours just like hacking or doing
whatever else and so for a lot of these
people I don't think we had caffeine at
the event I really want to say we did
not have caffeine in demand like these
people were up for the whole thing like
a whole weekend they were off just from
like just from having this natural
energy inside of them and so for them
it's just a matter of directing that
energy maybe from playing video games to
actually working on things yes yes and
one of my TV games one of my favorite
things about the hackathon organized is
that before that almost every hack of
every high school there's a so in the
space of hackathons there are caught
they're like the og hackathons maybe
College hackathon so I'm actually in
this in Michigan ten apps University
Penn there's a hack the North at
University of Toronto I believe and so
like these are these large events like
thousand plus people and then you have
high school hackathons which in the Bay
Area it's ridiculously a diluted
field where you have like this past year
there's like a high school hackathon
every weekend and so yeah and so like
it's great to see these things happen
you know that seconds although following
all that then you have
guys there's too many hacks and people
are not appreciating them and using them
for how they should spend a weekend in a
hackathon but with the high school
hackathons I've seen it just be a
general here's food here Soylent here
stickers and swag you're under our
supervision for 24 hours don't do
anything illegal you're fine and that
tends to be how it usually goes with my
hackathon we had at midnight we had this
it started off as a battle of the bands
cuz four people brought ukuleles to my
track so we had person played ukulele
after the next after the next and then
and then we turned it into a talent show
some people had acts of courage they're
doing magic tricks and then it turns
into improv and like the whole time
people have like bit like sheer joy and
enthusiasm in them like people describe
me as having this viev energy because
I'm always just fair enthusiastic about
things being able to share that to
others just like the energy and passion
about these things was a very exciting
part about half of the fog when we are
doing our presentations even though it
can be a scary experience because for a
lot of these people it was the first
hackathon like there's there certainly
any events in San Francisco they can do
they can go doing this in the first one
they could go to and so even though
there some of them were presenting for
the first time they were still like very
energetic and passionate about what they
made no matter if it was a small what
I've said they struggled with or it was
something they were very experienced
with and they were still able to deliver
that and that was a very awesome part
about working organizing this event and
even since when I go to another event or
I see some people from my hackathon that
other event they might come up to me
after it's like you know yeah if your
event was awesome like it's for some
people change them entirely some people
are some really awesome exciting
experience to go to and so being able to
see just how much of an impact you can
have on others and how much it does stay
with people is almost empowering and
motivating in itself as well yep and
then do you get to do something like
have other people take over after you go
to alright yes we are we are getting
hacked the fog - in the process of being
organized I sort of handed it off
because I have I'm focusing on like
getting ready for college work and other
things but it is definitely gonna happen
again
and
I will stay around just like hit people
in the head like make sure it's good to
make sure it's good yeah and then how
does one then with you know building up
the resume of leadership and mentorship
and running events like this how do you
make the decision to go across the
country for school well so with me I
apply to quite a large number of schools
there is maybe some things in the
college process that could have gone
better that I couldn't spend more time
on but looking at the options I got in
the end RIT
it's got its got a reputable enough of a
name here in the valley for engineering
like it's almost like University of
Waterloo and like it's people if you say
RIT people know what you mean and they
have a decent computer science program
and on top of that they but the nice
thing about RIT is that it has a NTID
National Technical Institute for the
deaf I think so because I'm deaf I get a
very reduced tuition and it got
scholarships on top of that so
financially it's like the whole all four
years would be the same price that's
going to another university I got
accepted into for one year yeah yeah and
so that makes a lot of fun yes and so
looking at where I am now where as of
today I have like a year of industry
experience I see an engineer not working
off at start with like actually send it
down to coding for software companies
and then by the end of the summer will
be closer to a year and a half so I'm
already in perhaps a primed position to
enter the industry so going to college
but and it's more for as a matter of
experience and then seeing a new place
another nice thing about RIT is that
it's all the way in upstate New York so
if I want to go Canada I can do that
it's near Niagara Falls there's nice
views and it's a very different
environment entirely where for me as an
SF native there are many things here in
San Francisco I their clients over take
for granted that simply do not exist in
other places so going to RIT were like
even though someone can tell me that
rent is ridiculously high I can get a
mansion for the price of studio here and
like you can tell me these things but
it's an it's one thing to know something
and it's another to understand something
and so that's another thing I'm hoping
to get out of going to our
tea cool and then how do you decide to
to not continue working in industry or
gota yeah well I mean I am hoping that I
can continue working in some capacity I
will definitely it might be remote it
might be you might be doing other
projects that still deliver an income
like there's nothing stopping me for
opening my laptop and I will probably
have plenty of time during the week to
do work so it's a matter of like piecing
that through when the time comes and so
once that set up I'll check my classes
I'll try to go to hacking related events
on campus you know still go to my dorm
room pop up in the laptop and I'll just
be working there
and so let's let's unpack both repli'd
and launch darkly so what were you doing
with them so repli'd was a sponsor at
HACC the fog and so in facebook Google
were - yes got them to sponsor yes
and so with repli'd so one of the things
about HACC the fog was matter of like we
had lots of workshops lined up in little
activities so people who were there at
the event they can learn something new
or they have very little coding
experience they can actually learn how
to make a website or something by the
end of the workshop and so following
this repli'd is a it's an online coding
environment rappelled NIT where if you
want to if you say have a Chromebook in
your classroom and you still want to
teach people computer science they can
use replic and so what are the
initiatives - that is helping making
coding more accessible to more people
and so this was obviously an exciting
initiative that I wanted to contribute
to and so last summer of my robust
growth engineer it was like a bit of a
developer evangelist I was going to
hackathons in New York Chicago given
talks organizing meetups here in the Bay
Area and just generally like helping
these helping foster these exciting
things and helping deliver applet to the
masses and so that was repli'd since
then i've been working as like a
softening intern or a contributing to
open source and now I'm currently
working at launch Darkly where I am a
software engineer intern and I am
right encode shipping software and what
are they doing what's not shark we're
doing a launch darkness so they provide
and they provide something called
feature flags where if you have a
website you and your run to add on a new
button or a new and in a new color theme
or something you don't want to just send
a new code to all your users what are
something breaks you can test it locally
but there's many other devices we roll
down on and so what if you could put
that new feature that new think behind a
toggle a flag so I get on/off and you
give it to 10% of users yeah that way if
it breaks you roll it back immediately
or if it does work you can just
increment you can incrementally roll it
out yeah so 10% 20% intervention that
you avoid out to all your users yes but
in that process it's safer it's a more
mature development process and that's
how you can get it out interesting and
so a lot of the big firms use processes
like this this incremental release and
so a lot of large company large tech
companies will usually develop this
in-house
but there's like the two big issues that
come of that the first one is
infrastructure where if you are going
with a feature flag different
development process you're probably
gonna have hundreds maybe even thousands
of flags being evaluated for every user
and if you're large companies say
Atlassian or Microsoft they have lots of
users like there's a lot of stuff going
on there and so you need make sure your
your flags don't break you want to keep
it up at all times the second thing is
this it's a more of a new idea of like a
developer experience just like this UX
UI a DX developer experience where you
want developer developers are spending
hours making these products and websites
it shouldn't be a pain in the ass for
them to do this and so with launch
directly we have of we have a large
assortment of variety of SDKs for many
different languages and many tools so
that as soon as you're on board with
launch directly the developers can get
going with by the way and it's a smooth
integration process that I've been in
the back over trying to add on some
internal middleware or whatever else
just so everything can fit through
nicely like they can get them over there
as soon as they start what's your
favorite programming language and why
well the thing is like at this point
I've bounced around between such a large
assortment of languages it's move
or like it's now it's more at the point
now it's like like you if you want to do
something you want to make an epic it
you want to make a website you want to
make a mobile app you can think more
based on actions like what needs to
exist and the language is just maybe a
slight change in syntax between each one
to actually carry through however for
the sake for the sake of the meme I
suppose I'll say i'll go ahead and say
lisp paul graham richard stallman big
names in computer science they all kind
of fall in line with loving this because
it's a it's the second oldest
programming language just a year old and
and Fortran if that's if that's name
some familiar and it's like in turn in
like visually if you're looking at say
list code compared to Python JavaScript
it's just terribly different because
everything is nested in parentheses
everything is done in post order and
there's a specific term for ordering
things with the operation first and the
arguments and everything altogether it's
like almost an art piece to read list
code compared to maybe a reactor
application or a website and so that's
like there's a aesthetic appeal to it
it's also a nice consequence of writing
in this biz that if you consider maybe
JavaScript there are there's always
going to be a few ways you can approach
some problem whether you're sorting
whether you're sorting something or
you're searching for some element with
some values there's always gonna be like
multiple approaches you could take and
so you can end up with like an
opinionated develop a development where
like maybe one developer will write it
one way but another person writing
another and you can either get confused
by reading the other person's code
whereas with this it can be somewhat
difficult to write opinionate code
because there's it's not restricted it's
more straightforward on how to and how
to approach problems and so there's
definitely that ok and so there's a
couple things here one of the things is
that you Illustrated this idea of like
you identify what you want to build and
then you kind of figure out what is the
most optimal way to build it and then
you pick which program you like you
don't need to you don't need to consider
the optimal way of approaching something
but
okay well like kind of I think it was
that I think was at the beginning of
this where I said like you are asking
about the direction of the future and
things how things are going if you just
if you have a clear idea of what you
want there's always there's going to be
multiple ways you can approach it so if
I wanted to make a website I could sit
down with the magnetic needle and a in a
processing ship and then put that
together or like I could spend tedious
and make make a website out of that or I
could sit down and I could make
something in HTML CSS or I could go make
some makeup up that website and Oh camel
reason or web assembly or JavaScript
there's many different pathways and
simulations if you will you can choose
your marriage curriculum and so it's
better if just like as soon as you have
that specific end goal there's gonna be
all these paths some are less
complicated some are more complicated
some more tedious less tedious well it's
a it's also a matter of how familiar you
are with these things like if I if you
are a seasoned front-end developer you
might be very the route that once was
tedious for you it's just a snap it's an
instant you're very smooth with it and
so you can easily approach that and so
with like making an application there's
you can always break it down into steps
like think of it as baking there's
always going to be different things
different foods you could create
different things you could cook or bake
or whatever like a cake with a cake if
you know I want a chocolate cake I don't
know enough about bacon to ramble on
this but uh you could say hey I could
start with either flour some baking soda
maybe whip it into a bowl then put it
into the oven or I could do something a
bit more vegan I could use different
ingredients or I maybe use a microwave
kit where I just simply toss it together
and a microwave it I have a cake and so
there's going to be different options
you have a cake in the end you have a
website in the end you have an
application again it's just that you
might have approached it differently or
there might be some racks are very
familiar with like a see like a very
experienced chef might always go with
bacon in the oven route because he's
very experienced with it to me it'd be a
pain in the ass like what the [ __ ] what
temperature's what is this and that but
to him it might be a different
experience and the same as with pro
I mean where you might have someone
choose one tool one language but if they
know just like breaking down into steps
and the recipe of it like they know
they're gonna need cake material whether
it's flour or something else they're
gonna need frosting whether it's organic
artificial they're gonna need these
things that you can break down just
steps like make the cake bad frosting
have a server out on the front end
whatever you to whatever tools use there
and so things can be broken down and
into like rules ingredients the outcome
of the cake and so it like things can be
broken down into atomic parts for
someone that's learning how to code and
this is definitely how I would run into
things that when I was first going to
hackathon jubileus I would see any
answer as being the only answer like
when I learned how to make a website
there's been like okay I finally learned
this is the only way there can be like
this is the only route when I make a
website there's the only thing I can do
but actor after going through it many
times I can see now like wait I know I
can just approach things more
conceptually I want a website now I see
oh there's not one way there's not one
only way there's all these things I'm at
hand and actually be annoyed approached
it that way yeah and then and then let's
um um let's circle into the very very
beginning because I'm I'm interested to
know what you think here Ron's 52 I'm 26
you're 18 you hang out with a lot of
other young kids you're already in Gen Z
and there's kids that are being born in
2019 soon kids being born in 2020 what
is kind of like the zeitgeist of your
generation of Gen Z well I mean I think
like the like the Ike I guess like what
I've been seeing more and more of
recently is how we're all kind of we're
all kind of human so I guess I've been
seeing more and more similarities
between people and my more accurate age
batch and people that are perhaps your
age or Ron's age and so I can probably
point out more similarities like we're
all kind of confused in this world that
we call life and earth and everything
else as for like the you
things I guess like one kind of more
unique things that this is nothing new
or novel is how we're almost like
digital citizens with digital natives
where for someone perhaps like you if
you were to be introduced to a new app
like some app comes out the process will
probably be like ok here's this app
there's like this strange thing that
happens I get some feedback here and
there but for so in my age to pick up a
new app or a new platform it'll probably
be a more smooth like ok another app oh
boy here we go I got the whole wallpaper
filled with everything else and they can
probably get interested into the role of
things where quickly I guess another
distinguishing feature it's just like
being more familiar and approachable to
new digital spheres and things as well
like did you get his graduation photo in
there too the very last one just wanna
make sure that we good looking photo of
you so I just want to make sure proud of
you you know and you're on your way with
this my homeroom started walking out we
like we were confused one to actually
finish this ceremony so we just started
walking out then like I figured like
we're not going to do the half throwing
because it's unsaved there's cardboard
and coroner's and everything and then
it's nice they don't do the hats clay
did I did not think they would and so
like we're almost at the door when I see
ok like [ __ ] so I just run picking my
hat and it would like first be into the
auditorium but I would every would have
Lydon so that's why I'm here without my
hat but uh continue continue on where
you're going you know your digital
technique so yeah the digital tech
natives like if there were a new app or
a new thing to roll out there'd be
probably a shorter time to being to
immediately approach intermedia
installing or getting familiar with it
for people my age then perhaps your age
just because like if lo of like being
attached to your phone and getting into
these things does not smooth ER I'm sure
every generation has this but there's
also a bit of like jargon or slang that
comes
as well so it's like a very different
like with writing texts or emails if I'm
ready if I'm sending an email to you and
Ron it might be very text-based like
just looking at the ideas proper grammar
and everything but there's a like if
you're sending the text to someone a bit
younger
you'll probably add it there will be
improper grammar you might use different
punctuation totally you need repeat
letters and stuff like it's just it's
fascinating how like these things that
would be considered errors at first they
can add so much more meaning to the way
you speak and it's all sort cuts they're
faster yes four types of things like
that I agree that that's a very good
point about the adaptation and how
quickly it's it's also really cool how
using adding on this layer of
punctuation as letters or whatever else
and I different jargony terms you can
it's almost like you can convey spoken
speech into the text rewrite yeah and so
if you're Russian and so like you can
indicate things with like maybe a
questionable tone that you might only be
able to describe with body language but
inside text how do you do that well if
you just like if you are you sure and
you just repeat 'yes like i know like
those kinds of things like you and when
you read it you know it means something
else then are you sure like it's not
just robotic are you sure like there's
more to it yeah I mean obviously can get
I like that that kind of stuffs good you
have what's going on with the youth and
there do you feel like like our anxiety
is anxiety a thing with the social media
if society as in young people with Gen Z
a anxiety Oh anxiety yeah I think like
that's I think there's a there's a
general anxiety with everyone I do think
it will come at different degrees or
rage for different people so for people
my age at least like say within my
graduating class in high school there's
going to be a different approach and
realization your anxiety as people your
age because for you and Ron you've
already moved out of the house you are
having to work for a living you can't
just leave off your parent anymore
people my age were younger we're also
delivering the rent parents like I still
live with my parents because I work here
in the Bay Area and so because of that
like there's maybe some concerns maybe
taxes or other things that don't that
don't have so much of an imminent doom
lurking over a city well and so maybe in
a few years after college one we're all
moved out and we're all in our 20s and
we're all in the industry they will be
our my generation will see the same
exact that you do now and so it's like
it's definitely age based and whatever
phase in life people are in okay what
what are some of the things that the gen
Z is piecing together to tackle some of
like the UN sustainable development
goals these types of things like do you
feel like there's like a good amount of
activism and what are the ideas that are
going on in the young virgin well I
think like there's I I think there's a
perhaps the same rate of activism within
every age group it just so happens that
with my age group because we're more
digital natives we can rely on social
media to spread things better like
there's probably if you were to compare
a five-year age block like with my group
in your group it's probably the same
percentages of people that are actually
activists but because my age block is
more familiar with Instagram and Twitter
and can spread a meme where they can
spread a hashtag at a much more rapid
patient in your group can then you get
like a Greta the sixteen-year-old Swede
I believe you can get these things
spread and faster and be more prominent
on the face of the news also at the same
time people like saying oh the young
they're ambitious they're gonna change
the world for the better but it's really
only a matter of like being people
sharing things in social media there is
I can't say there's any difference in
attitude towards issues within my age
group and your age group I think it's
like if this is if there's any notable
difference probably do that people my
age group are more likely to be properly
educated and they're gonna be more
affirming of science and like I guess
like that typical mess in that typical
statement where people my age group out
of everyone my age there might be a
higher percentage of people recognizing
global warming as a problem
compared to people your age group
because there might be a difference in
education standards between those
periods okay I want to ask you a couple
other questions let's ask you about what
do you think happens before were birth
into the world and what do you think
happens after we die what happens before
war in the world I guess it's a like us
as humans were all sort of these not
cogs and the giant machine but we're all
make like have you ever seen this cute
simulations of bacteria bouncing around
like that's all we really are and so
where do you think we come from before
even that well come from somewhere well
a mom and a dad love each other very
much and say oh you mean like before
like going before the context is reality
and such yeah do we come from somewhere
else into these earth suits like
conscious conscious wise I think I could
probably argue open individualism that
kind of what Andres Gomez and then
Andres Gomez puts about where we're all
kind of part of this like we all share
the same consciousness if you will like
arguments for this can be brought up
with maybe some cute physics paradoxes
and how we kind of we're all kind of one
like as in like not one master hive mind
but like we're all kind of fitting
together into one global consciousness
and then following us that will the
story will continue we just might not
know what follows us sir and so whether
that means we are in a simulation we you
can ask you that one next are we in a
simulator are we in a simulation I think
it's I think it's very much reasonable
to think so I think it's like I don't
think the matter of do we live in a
computer simulation is so much of an
important question to tackle I would say
yes just for giggles I think it's I
think the simulation viewpoint of life
is a very fun one because like when
you're thinking to your day or your
planning things out you are running a
simulation in your head where you're
like kind of putting together different
variables different ideas and so you are
kind of you're making a simulation so
that could be very it would be hubris to
think that that's immolation in her head
is not one we're in and so it's but like
right now me I'm a memory effectively
your it could be me remembering this
discussion or it could be you 50 years
down the road remembering this and
that's kind of how things come about and
then when he thinks your most
controversial belief my most
controversial believe God this was a
brought about the group house as a
question I don't know I mean I guess
like the only controversial in like
plain on the word controversial would be
that the most interesting things come
when you're highly opinionated like oh
so like you like people try to be try to
obtain high great bonuses one of the big
five personality trait I think things
are a lot more exciting if you go for
low agreeableness like there might be a
consequence of narcissism from that but
at least you are bringing about more
information from that and so I will
either try to like I will either try to
push people's buttons or be very
strongly opinionated I might be wrong
let me thesis antithesis yeah and the
synthesis and so like I might be wrong I
might be arguing a bad point I might be
just being too much of a troll but at
least there's more things revealed from
that than if you were to not bring it
about at all kind of like a like if you
were to just stick with the if you're to
be high agreeableness and just go with
what people bring about you all tend to
just float along we'd be the surface
level conversations or such I mean it's
like a neat idea I thought of that I
think applies really well is it's almost
like this Venn diagram when it comes to
conversations like you have me imagine
like this circle of all the things you
know and all the things you can say and
there's a circle of what I know there's
like an overlap in that you know and we
will start any conversation in that
overlap and so that's funny for most
people you say did you go shopping
everyone go shopping there's sometimes
overlap there's a nice thing in overlap
and then if you're both at a tech event
you probably talk about technology news
whatever yeah and the conversation
progresses as you
in more more from your circle into that
overlap until you both overlap and now
you're you know everything the other
person knows the more opinion good luck
with that guitar - yes but that's the
like it's kind of like when economics
the long run in the long run we'll both
okay we'll both be the same circle and
the more highly opinionated statements
you can make the more surface area on
your end you're bringing in because
there's a difference there's a different
disparity between what you have and I
have that we can explore a larger
breadth of conversation there I like
that I like that it's a good
controversial statement on
disagreeableness I like that one there's
a lot of nuance I can get big yet begun
to if you do that well and then last
question is what he thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world
god there's so many cheesy that's just
gonna give I think like the most
beautiful thing in the world is kind of
everything all together I suppose kind
of like because like the going back to
the idea of simulations and thinking the
memories and different pathways there's
a very small impetus much ants that we
end up where we are now like it could
very well be that I may have ended up
Malloy consciousness whatever component
of the consciousness ended up in Ron's
body instead or at somewhere else and
yet with all these things tying together
from the like even just looking at the
scale of the universe for billion the
lifetime of Earth four billion years and
all the things like that we'll all the
all the atoms and particles smashed
together in the pristine ways just so we
could get to here right now yeah
and so having everything all in this
pristine like very precise divide the
circumstance is probably the most
beautiful thing there is love it love it
yeah very well said it's a beautiful
beautiful pinnacle that we are at right
now it's only going up therefore it's
only going up further and further yes
yeah that's just an opinion you yeah
that's a optimistic opinion okay see one
of the things make sure that the young
kids don't end up they keep the
positivity the optimism keeper be
realistic about just keep the
observation in optimism energy going
well last night I had an epiphany of
sorts where you can like if I believe in
a utopian future I will arrive at a
utopian future in a fight don't believe
if I believe in it we're screwed like I
always say that's where my life will go
thought his creation if we get 8 billion
people working in the direction of
utopia because we believe in us there's
parallax's that happen along the way so
we can keep working on the ideas over
time but yeah that's how we can we
really get there yep
thank you mine this is good super
pleasure
yes pleasure from you as well good I'm
really glad to hear that it's been a
blast
your big inspiration to us and keep up
this good work ok now keep up the spirit
is hustle you've done a great job so far
so please firing other people and I hope
those that were tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love for you to give
your thoughts in the comments below in
the episode also get engaging more with
young people in your communities they're
inspirational get talking to them get
learning from them and also talk to them
ask them questions about their lives and
what's going on with them and the even
younger generations because they're the
ones we pass along the control of the
earth to also check out the links in the
Bible oh - yeah bar his Facebook's
LinkedIn profiles also share the content
with more people Ron thank you for
producing and directing we greatly
appreciate it and also do cool things
like design awesome merch and get paid
for it it's most beautiful thing in the
world spread these thought-provoking
questions that links in the BIOS or a
patreon or PayPal cryptocurrency links
are down there support the artists and
entrepreneurs and your community support
us if you believe in us and go and build
the future everyone manifest those
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in we'll see you soon
Hey
[Music]